[Music]
[Music]
straight
the night is dark and full of terrors oh
wait a minute that's the wrong universe
well it's the same so here in this video
we will showcase 10 types of vampires of
the marvel universe with special
emphasis on morbius and then a short
description on the other subspecies of
vampires which will include the likes of
dracula and blade altogether with
morbius the living vampire all these
beings have super strength agility and
endurance but they also differ from each
other in many other ways aspects like
origins or special abilities and even
their form and appearance so let's look
into them
let's start with the original vampire
who isn't dracula but another being that
once walked the earth by the name of
vani
the atlantean cult of dark holders
exploited the power of catholic scrolls
from the dark hole to create vampires in
the pre-cataclysmic era some 20 000
years ago vane
one of their own was raised as the
world's first vampire as a result vana
immediately dispatched the remaining
dark holders and utilized them to
establish a vampire race naming himself
the vampire lord he had all the powers
of a vampire and vulnerabilities such as
vulnerabilities to silver crucifixes and
sunlight he was worshipped as a god baal
and later as sathogua by various peoples
of in the past but then later on both of
his existence he passed on his powers to
dracula in the year 1459 and then
committed suicide in sunlight
now let's look at morbius unlike other
vampires who are undead mobius is a
living vampire well he experimented on
vampire bad blood and injected himself
with a serum that he hoped would cure
his blood disease but unfortunately he
became a vampire his face would morph
into a resemblance of a bat in his
vampiric state his bones also become
somewhat hollow allowing him to fly by
riding wind currents
his new shape also improves his senses
and offers him more stamina speed
strength and durability unfortunately he
needs to feed on blood in order to
survive therefore he was first seen as a
villain but later on as an anti-hero of
sorts while he possesses many
traditional vampire strengths he does
not have their same weaknesses towards
the sun garlic and other religious
artifacts he can regenerate injured
tissue but then he is not invulnerable
and can be hurt severely with enough
force
so this next type of vampire is a very
well known one
and might include just one
individual
this one includes the likes of blade he
was born a human and a vampire hybrid
and the enzymes in blade's blood made
him immune to normal vampire bites
making him uniquely attuned to sensing
the supernatural and he was resistant to
aging later after being bitten by
morbius blade then gained some of the
traditional powers of the vampires
without developing their weaknesses well
he has superhuman strength senses and
stamina plus an accelerated healing
factor although blade does not have any
of the weaknesses of all the other
vampires he still did possess one
weakness common to all the need to feed
on fresh blood in order to stay alive
however rather than consume blood he
injects himself a specially designed
serum that provides even better
nourishment than blood but without it he
would slowly succumb to his vampiric
instincts and attack humans
now we come to the different subspecies
of vampires starting with the tricks the
tricks tryks are a subspecies of vampire
and they differ in many ways to regular
vampires tricks do not feed on humans
but prefer to attack and feed on other
vampires
the tricks live in a kind of a hive with
most of their numbers
being male and female being the queen of
the hive like bees and ants all the
tricks have claws embedded in their
palms and can be used as weapons they
produce a sharp spike from their chin
which can paralyze humans and vampires
which also stops them from
disintegrating after death meaning the
vampires the poison in the spikes is a
catalyst to start the transformation
process this process goes on three
different stages first parallelizing the
hose then form some kind of a symbiosis
and later transformation
next the charni putra now these strange
subspecies of uh vampires are gargle
like in nature they are bulky and have a
face of a bat and huge wings that come
out from their backs achaaniputras
mostly fly above mountains such as the
himalayas
with their great wings spending most or
all of their time feeding in the sky
charlie putras also have a tough height
that is hard to damage without the
weaknesses that is silver bullets and
blades or arrows made of silver although
they are very reclusive they still do
attend a vampire gathering once every
century
next we have the adzae these are a race
of african vampires that can survive
being staked through the heart the usual
instantaneous method of killing a
vampire they could still survive for
around 10 minutes due to their massive
adrenaline rushes this means that they
are more vicious and stronger than the
regular vampires and can fight for a
longer time beheading seems to be the
better solution to take them out
next we have the pseudo vampires well
there's another group of these vampiric
beings that even though aren't real
vampires they still do exhibit many of
their traits and their origins are
unlike that of blade or mobius so these
two heroes won't be included along with
them they are the demon balls disciples
and had many of the same characteristics
as typical vampires
they weren't actual vampires though they
were fake fangs and were unaffected by
ultraviolet rays but they did consume
human blood bal the demon gave strength
on his servants making them stronger
faster and more durable yet they still
lack true superhuman qualities these
pseudo vampires come from the gehenna
region in the middle east mostly around
israel and have been worshipping baal
for around 15 000 years
[Music]
next we have the aqueous this one has
quite a number of races in its foe
the aqueous are a vampire group
composed of at least three distinct
supernatural races the atlanteans the
faceless ones and one more unidentified
race that is more or less connected to
ancient evil beings and the great old
ones they have all the abilities and
weaknesses of the surface living
vampires
they can convert atlanteans and humans
into vampires much like their surface
cousins they have the advantage over the
surface dwellers as sunlight cannot
reach the deepest depths of the ocean so
they can swim along whatever time they
want to they also have vampires a lot of
underwater creatures over the thousands
of years of their existence
second last we have the yiki ona the
ikiona are snow vampires of japan
spending their time as clouds of razor
sharp eyes most of their time at least
and only turning into a humanoid form to
feed their motives and most of their
history is relatively unknown but are
thought to be the ones behind the
japanese folklore spirits of the same
name
then lastly we have the husky
these are a variation of vampires who
are revived as virtually mindless
creatures trying to accomplish one last
task from their human life before being
destroyed they only follow their base
instinct and feed on small animals they
will not rest until they have completed
a task from their human life
anyway with that we come to the end of
this video so do hit that like button
for support and subscribe as well to be
a part of the mind cue family but most
of all smash the bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one take care fam